how does that all interplay with the
infamous Gill the goal the global
interpreter lock
maybe can you say what the Gill is and
how does it dance beautifully with Ace
in Kyle
the global interpreter lock
solves the problem that python
originally was not written with either
asynchronous or or parallelism in mind
at all there was no concurrency in the
language there was no parallelism there
were no threads
only a small number of years into
Python's initial development
all the new cool operating systems like
uh Sun OS and silicon graphics irex and
then eventually posix and windows all
came with threading libraries
that lets you do multiple things in
parallel and there is a certain
certain sort of principle which is the
operating system handles the threads for
you
and the program can pretend that there
are as many CPUs as as there are threads
in the program
uh and those CPUs were completely
independently
and if you don't have enough CPUs the
operating system sort of simulates those
extra CPUs on the other hand if you have
enough CPUs you can get a lot of work
done by deploying those multiple CPUs
but python wasn't written
to to do that
uh and so
as libraries for for multi-threading
were added to C
but every operating system vendor was
adding their own version of that
we thought and maybe we were wrong but
at the time we thought well we quickly
want to be able to support these
multiple threads
because they seemed at the time in the
early 90s when they were new at least to
me
they seemed a cool interesting
programming Paradigm and one of the
things that that python at least at the
time
felt was nice about the language was
that we could give a
safe version of all kinds of cool new
operating system toys to the python
programmer like I remember
one or two years before threading I I
had spent some time adding networking
sockets
to Python and they were very literal
translation of the networking sockets
that were in the BSD operating system so
Unix BSD
but the nice thing was if you're using
sockets from python then all the things
you can do wrong with sockets in C would
automatically give you a clear error
message instead of just ending up with a
malfunctioning hanging program
and so we thought well we'll do the same
thing with threading
but we didn't really want to rewrite The
Interpreter
to be thread safe because that that was
was like
that would be a very complex refactoring
of all The Interpreter code and all the
runtime code because all the objects
were written with the assumption that
there is only one thread and so we said
okay well we'll take our losses we'll
provide something that looks like
threads
and as long as you only have a single
CPU on your computer which most
computers at the time did
uh it feels just like threads because
the the whole idea of of multiple
threads in the OS was that even if your
computer only had one CPU you could
still fire up at many threads as you
wanted well within reason maybe 10 or 12
not 5000.
uh and so we thought we had conquered
the
the abstraction of threads pretty well
because multi core uh CPUs were were not
in in most python programmers hands
anyway
and then of course a couple of more
iterations of Moore's Law and computers
getting faster and at some point
uh the chip designers decided that they
couldn't make the CPUs faster but they
could still make them smaller and so
they could put multiple CPUs on one chip
and suddenly there was all this pressure
about
do things in parallel and that's where
the the solution we had in Python didn't
work
and that's that's sort of the moment
that the Gill became
became infamous
because the guilt the guilt was the
solution we used to sort of
take this single interpreter and share
it between all the different operating
system threats that you could create and
so as long as the the hardware
physically only had one CPU that was all
fine
and then as Hardware vendors were
suddenly telling us all oh you got to
paralyze everything's got to be
paralyzed
people started saying oh uh but we can
use multiple threads in Python and uh
then they discovered oh but actually all
threads run on a single single core yeah
I mean is there a way is there ideas for
in the future to remove
the global interpreter log Gill like
maybe multiple sub interpreters some
tricky
interpreters on top of interpreters kind
of thing yeah there there are a couple
of possible uh Futures there the
the most likely future is that we'll get
multiple sub interpreters
which each run a completely independent
Python program nice uh but they're
they're still some benefit of
of sort of faster communication between
those programs but it's also managing
for you this running a multiple python
programs like yeah so it's hidden from
you right the it's it's hidden from you
but you have to spend more time
communicating between those programs
because the sort of
the attractive thing about the
multi-threaded model is that the threads
can share objects at the same time
that's also the downfall of the
multi-threaded programming model because
when you do share objects
you were and you didn't necessarily
intend to share them or uh there were
aspects of those objects that
that were not reusable you get all kinds
of concurrency bugs and so
the reason I wrote that little blog post
about semaphores was that concurrency
bugs are just harder it would be nice if
python had uh no Global interpreter lock
and it had the so-called free threading
but it would also cause a lot more
software bugs
uh the interesting thing is that there
is still a possible future where we are
actually going to or where we could
experiment at least with that
because there is a guy working for
Facebook who has developed a fork of C
python
that he called the no-gill
interpreter where he removed the Gill
and made a whole bunch of optimizations
so that the the single threaded case
doesn't run too much slower
and multi-threaded case will actually uh
use all the cores that you have
and so that that would be an interesting
possibility
if we would be willing as a python core
developers to actually
uh maintain that code indefinitely
and if we're willing to put up with the
additional complexity of The Interpreter
and the additional sort of overhead for
the single threaded case and I'm
personally not convinced
that
there are enough people
uh needing the speed of multiple threads
with their python programs
that it's worth to sort of
take that performance hit and that
complexity hit
and I I feel that the Gill actually is
pretty nice
Goldilocks point between no threads and
uh all threads all the time but not
everybody agrees on that so that is
definitely a possible future the sub
interpreters look like a fairly safe bet
for 312 so say a year from now